hey this is presh talwalkar
find the sum of the following series
1 over the quantity 1 times 2 plus 1
over the quantity 2 times 3 plus 1 over
the quantity 3 times 4
plus etc going on to infinity
this problem was asked as part of the
cambridge exam for students seeking a
bachelor of arts in 1802
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
to solve this infinite series we're
going to consider a specific term of the
series which has the form
one over the quantity n times n plus one
one way that we can simplify this term
is that we can decompose it into simple
fractions
we can do this using the method of
partial fractions
specifically we want to make this term
equal to the sum of two fractions
it'll be some fraction a over n plus
another fraction b over n plus one
and it'll be easier to evaluate this
infinite series if we look at fractions
which only have one term in the
denominator
so to solve this equation we're going to
multiply both sides by n times n plus
one
we end up with the equation that one is
equal to a times the quantity n plus one
plus b times n
now we expand the right hand side and
group like terms
we can see from this equation that we
need the constant term of a to be equal
to one
and we need the coefficient of n which
is a plus b to be equal to zero
so we have a system of equations where a
is equal to one and a plus b is equal to
zero
we can solve this very easily that a is
equal to one and b is equal to negative
one
so we figured out how to decompose our
general term into simple fractions as
follows
we have that one over the quantity n
times n plus one is equal to one over n
minus one over n plus one
so how is this going to help us solve
our infinite series
well let's take a look at the sum of our
series up to k terms
from this partial sum let's take a look
at just the very first term of this sum
we have 1 over the quantity one times
two
well let's apply our formula
to decompose this into two simple
fractions
so the very first term will be equal to
one over one minus one over two
we can now apply the formula to the
second term
this will be equal to one over two minus
one over three
when we apply it to the third term we're
going to have one over three minus one
over four
now we can continue applying this
formula to the rest of the terms in this
series
so now we can see a very magical
cancellation happens
here we have negative one-half and then
positive one-half
those terms will cancel out
we then have negative one-third and a
positive one-third
those terms will cancel out
this pattern continues we have negative
1 4 and plus 1 4 and that will also
continue and we go all the way where all
of these middle terms keep cancelling
out
now if you consider
a retracting telescope the pattern that
we have in the series is very familiar
to the shape of a retracting telescope
we can expand it out all the way but we
can also contract it where we only have
the very beginning and the very end
surviving so just like that our series
is like an expanded telescope and now
we've cancelled out all these terms in
the middle and we've retracted it back
to the smaller form
for this reason this type of series is
known as a telescoping series
so now we have very simple form of the
sum up to the k terms of this infinite
series
we then calculate the sum of the
infinite series by letting k go to
infinity
now one over k plus one will go to zero
and therefore
our infinite series will have the sum
that's exactly equal to one
so that's the answer to this problem
now i know some of you might say this is
a little bit too easy but this exam was
actually pretty hard for anyone who
thinks this problem was too easy you're
welcome to try the very next question on
the exam
if half of the earth were taken off by
the impulse of a comet what change would
be produced in the moon's orbit
i don't know the answer and i could not
quickly figure out the answer from doing
a few internet searches so if you know
the answer to this question please share
your knowledge in the comments
did you figure out the original problem
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions which you can follow on
facebook google plus and patreon you can
catch me on social media at
preshellwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description